bonsoir ali barra merci d'être avec nous
des attaques simultanées à kidal ménaka
et gao clairement que chercher à faire
les terroristes alors sacrée les groupes
radicaux violents au nord et au centre
dumas deal it in le quotidien des
populations 2012
certes les différentes réponses à
apporter à la france elle a porté
également par l'armée régulière du mali
ainsi que s'élève la face au dynamisme
en permis d'assister à un débit telle
qu'elle est consciente quand même qu'ici
les coups violents notamment à l'autre
d'un trésor du mali c'est que l'état
frontière avec l'état islamique ont uni
a sévit de façon tout à fait remarquable
rappelons quand même que 2019 a
aujourd'hui le malinois travers ses
différentes phases de sécurité à pogny
maman des victimes de la guerre des
monnaies est également une bonne partie
également des françaises et même la
force onusienne a également été touchée
également par ses attaques répétées
passé face à la fois onusienne dans
marianne pourquoi ces attaques
aujourd'hui quel est ce timing je pense
que plus un hypothèse est plausible
parmi celles ci il faut quand même
évoqué l'attitude plus ou moins
rigoureuse de la france où sont les
généraux du dialogue
cette vie pour lesquels viennent la btk
ne méritait pas un homme important des
maliens lors des assises qui ont humilié
en 2010 cette même scène 2009 dans les
mêmes temps on peut aussi comprendre un
des puits des attaques considérant que
vous pourrez voir notamment la parole de
la part de la face bakhan française
c'est quand même une réponse aussi assez
différent de la tête vous pouvez aux
différentes façons en présence que les
phase 2
mais le goût à l'école a récement
seulement musique dans le même temps et
continue à inquiéter à la fois et les
populations civiles est même un
militaire dont je pense que c'est un
message fort qui venait placer face au
boucau violents à l'encontre de
différentes façons mais emmanuel m on
veut repenser justement l'opération
barkan avec davantage d'européens à ses
côtés c'est selon vous une bonne option
stratégique
alors concrètement aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
analyse de façon directive les licences
des dépenses militaires sont proposés
par le quai d'orsay sans s'appeller
pense qu'ils sont quand même tout à fait
sa mue et mais elles ne suffisent pas
pour des raisons tout à fait évidente
beaucoup de maliens et l'édition
opération militaire n'était pas aussi le
dc10 en attaque terroriste lesquels
opérations militaires notamment
étrangère souffrent également démis
réelle coordination avec les fonds
consentis par les éléments de la force
de défense et de sécurité l'appui du
maire de carleton
sommes nous en face des actions
véritables logements qui ne tiennent pas
suffisamment compte de toute la
dimension humaine nous voir un projet
construit bout ce que s'y tenait déjà
aujourd'hui quand même la france est
elle apporté pas mal de réponses
militaires même l'humanitaire mais
lesquelles elle planche malheureusement
et peine avalé un ancrage local ne parle
plus simple c'est que sont les réponses
qui souffrent des six ans de formation
et même le collaboration avec les autres
sans que lance effectivement
l'instabilité semble extrêmement
difficile à gommer pourquoi est ce si
compliqué c'est quasiment une mission
impossible selon vous il est important
de l'appliquer
lorsque le tourisme sympathie et il faut
le long terme serait que très souvent on
succombe sensationnel
si vous voulez on raccourcit même dans
une partie du monde sont nous parvenir à
éradiquer mais pour lui ce soit dans un
laps de temps que le longtemps il est
vraiment nécessaire même s'il est
difficilement compréhensible par les
communautés notamment celles qui vivent
à aucun de ses différentes formes de
violence mais je pense que
fondamentalement il redit cette
persistance de l'insécurité
interroge à la fois la nature du
financement qui sont apportées dès 2013
à horizon 10 mais dans le même temps ça
c'est aussi thème l'épineuse question de
collaboration notamment la france marque
française la force au musée de la misma
et la force défense des inculpés du mali
centaines d acte est certes qui s'est
battu contre le limiter les mii qui est
l'étoile dix mois mais malheureusement
les quelques combats mous montrent à
suffisance que souffle le corps mais son
souffle même de collaboration des façons
ces petits gants de sédition d'année
merci à lee sociologue directeur du
centre des études sécuritaires et
stratégiques au sel merci d'avoir été
avec nous avoir apporté notre analyse